[Music]
after spider-man no way home and the
gigantic multiverse story everything
seems possible many people want to see
andrew garfield as the amazing
spider-man again which is why the
question of the possible third part with
him in the lead role is not too
far-fetched in a conversation with
variety the 38 year old talked about
exactly this scenario and as expected
directly gave the all clear of course he
also knows that his credibility has
suffered somewhat since his last
appearance but he is still telling the
truth he also responded to his social
media trend whose content is possible
the amazing spider-man 3. however
garfield left open whether his
cancellation also included an appearance
in a supporting role with tom holland
either way we'll be hearing a lot more
about the friendly spider from the
neighborhood in the future after all
there are still three movies with tom
holland in development
the news that jason momoa will play a
role in fast and furious 10 surprised
many fans around the world after
numerous speculations about them still
unknown role we now finally know in
which direction his character will go as
he himself confirmed to entertainment
tonight he will become an extremely
flamboyant villain he himself said it
would be fun to play the bad guy again
after a long time sounds interesting
we'll definitely keep you posted on more
news about the new edition production on
fast and furious 10 is scheduled to
start this spring with a movie expected
to be released on may 19 2023
when netflix released a trailer for a
movie called cliff b6 the battle for
everest last wednesday many were
initially at a loss as to what this
trash movie was all about it quickly
became clear that cliff b6 was not the
sixth part of a mysterious movie series
but a promo from netflix new movie the
bubble this adventure comedy starring
stars like pedro pascal karen gillian
david duchovny and leslie mann and maria
bakalova revolves around a group of
actors stuck in a hotel during the
pandemic there really isn't much boredom
however because they are working
together on cliff b6 the sixth part of a
fictional movie series about dinosaurs
in fact the movie is obviously based on
the upcoming jurassic world three even
though there is no official mention of
it behind the project is director judd
apatow who is not known for action-heavy
adventure movies like jurassic world and
the like but rather for romantic
comedies like train wreck we are curious
to see how epitaph's comedy will be
received by viewers and ironically are
looking forward to april 1st 2022 when
the movie is scheduled to be released on
netflix
disney is currently working at full
speed on a new superhero series about
the iron man successor iron heart
filming is scheduled to start in april
and recently there was new information
about the cast in addition to leading
actress dominic thorne we will also see
larry ross and anthony ramos in new
roles ramus who also starts and
transforms seven rise of the beasts will
have a key role in the disney plus
series what exactly is closely guarded
role look like can only be guessed at
the moment however it is said to be
indeed a character that will be of great
importance in the upcoming mcu movies
and series the role of 18 year old
actress colleague lyric ross is not
known but the hollywood reporter
suspects that she plays the best friend
of protagonist riri williams this series
revolves around the life of young riri
williams who's a similarly ingenious
tinkerer to the late tony stark just
like her predecessor the introverted
riri builds her own iron man suit while
enrolled at the massachusetts institute
of technology or mit unfortunately the
iron heart series doesn't have a start
date yet however a first glimpse of
leading actress dominique thorne will be
available in black panther wakanda
forever on november 11th 2022
for many years it has been clear that in
some way a fifth indiana jones movie
will be released then last sunday
producer frank marshall released a
picture of a cap with the word indie on
it announcing the completion of the
lengthy filming process after three
extremely highly regarded indiana jones
movies as well as the more or less
revolved kingdom of the crystal skull
expectations for the late sequel are
high the production had to contend with
many problems including the unplanned
search for a new director the
restrictions imposed by the pandemic and
ambiguities in writing the script this
in turn led to a total of four postponed
start dates which may not have caused
much enthusiasm among fans either
unfortunately nothing is yet known about
this story but there have been rumors of
a new nazi storyline time travel is also
rumored to play a role we know a lot
more about the cast of indiana jones 5.
in addition to 79 year old leading man
harrison ford we will also be able to
see much mickelson phoebe waller bridge
antonio banderas and boyd holbrook and
yet unknown roles on the big screen
directing as well as a feature
screenwriter was james mangold who
co-wrote the current trip with jess and
john henry butterworth indiana jones 5
is expected to be released in the us on
june 30th 2023
the production of the comic adaption
craven the hunter seems to be
progressing well as it was recently
announced that a new actress has joined
the cast it is west side story star
ariana debose who won a golden globe
this year for her role as anita she is
now to play an ally of the main
character craven the hunter she goes by
the name calypso in the original comics
calypso is the declared anime of
spider-man and co in stands by craven as
a close ally she is the one who made his
superpowers possible in the first place
and some even suggest that she will have
a love affair with craven in the movie
the voodoo priest's particular strength
lie in brewing her potions which always
give the consumers superhuman powers in
craven's case this is mainly his
extraordinary strength speed and slow
aging process the cast also includes
aaron taylor johnson as craven russell
crowe as craven's father and fred
hashinger as dimitri smith yakov better
known as chameleon the latter by the way
is also craven's half-brother and
together they have a lot of fun making
spider-man's life miserable craven the
hunter will be released in the west on
january 13 2023
27 years ago sony computer entertainment
released the first spin-off of the
twisted metal series which is a mixture
of a shooter and a racing game after a
movie adaption announced in 2012 never
appeared sony decided to pack the story
into a series at the beginning of 2019.
filming has so far failed to materialize
but it has now been announced that
streaming service peacock has secured
the rights and will air the series in
the role we see sam wilson actor anthony
mackie who portrays john doe who suffers
from amnesia john doe is a talkative
milkman who delivers a mysterious
package in dangerous post-apocalyptic
glance and has to face off against less
friendly fellows along the way according
to officials twisted metal is said to be
an adrenaline-fueled comedy series the
plot is based on the well-known
playstation games and is conceived by
the two deadpool riders redress and paul
vernick incidentally among the countless
enemies jondo will have to face is the
clown who drives a familiar ice cream
truck and should look familiar to fans
of the franchise it is not yet known
when exactly the twisted metal series
will be released
slowly but surely disney has moved most
of its movies and series to its own
streaming service disney plus not yet
included of various series about marvel
characters that have appeared on netflix
in recent years included are the
punisher daredevil jessica jones luke
cage iron fist the defenders at marvel's
agents of shield which will be available
on disney plus starting march 16th for
now however this arrangement only
affects the us canada the uk ireland
australia and new zealand and the rest
of the world it will not be until later
in the year the question of whether the
series will then also be part of the mcu
canon remains exciting there has been no
official statement on this yet
we hope you enjoyed our news this week
make sure to check out our latest
original on a possible young avengers
movie there we present you all the
characters that could appear as well as
possible story lines from the comic
books we also recommend the first
trailer for the new action movie bullet
train with brad pitt
[Music]
oh
[Music]